hi I'm William Saunders and I'm 21 years
old and screenwriter from the Midlands
what's this year in the UK year from the
university would stir in screenwriting
and I'm exploring this brilliant
industry and seeing how far I can get
and pushing us out to the limit now with
writing being a screen right at four
since I start 2012 which was was
interesting to get into because I didn't
have a clue what screenwriting was I
didn't really know I hadn't explored it
before so i went to the university was
to try and get in there doing english
literature and language and they said to
me have you thought about screenwriting
have you thought about about writing
scripts and i said was hi I work
honestly haven't thought I haven't
thought about doing that before hadn't
looked to death and they said well you
know come along see if y'all again it's
just blossomed from there really in this
creative world this idea that you can
take anything and build upon it and an
idea just a character build up character
create this fantastic story went on to
write a number of different scripts
different genres it were just everything
their original and they were what I
wanted to write about they want it what
I wanted to say up to the world what I
wanted to story I wanted it out all got
a bit me and then I think and you know
they range from comedy its share there's
a sitcom mockumentary style which I
absolutely love and right through to
doing sci-fi you know my friends starve
episode 7 coming out willkommen script
on working on has been a
there's one I'm ones that I'm looking at
for a job then working for the moment
there there's kind of a script
consultant mentor kind of role to their
children which helping them understand
the screenwriting for marketing and how
it's different to theatre how it's
different to format there but the script
I've been working on three minutes trips
there and thoroughly enjoyed get been
sculpting those quick taking their ideas
and you know not noting down what they
come up with and then then put me on in
the format formatting it and put it into
a story in corona you know throwing
thats for a film festival so we're
really looking for that sheet at the
moment and so that's really encouraging
and but think that i've got a project a
web series that i wanna go into
obviously please make and put on youtube
later date which follows a man who is
lost everything in life is his his
wife's left him for his fortune free
writing partner and he's a gente dana
that jobs inside and he wants to do
something more so he perceives being the
company stand-up comedian and meets
several interesting characters an online
reason i haven't quit as a screamer yeah
well no any script is when people down
with that you're not going anywhere
you're not gonna do any good in this
career you're not gonna thrive and i
keep i look at I'm going I'm going to
prove you wrong let's let's write
something that lets even write that
story let's let's go there with that
let's see how far we can take it and
then just finish me on sir but I've been
told of the time feat I've given you no
good constructive criticism and then be
given bad criticism which that is right
you never want you've got to take their
practices and riches which is helpful my
goal yeah with the web series would be
to produce and
and then made them so that they can be
watched on youtube I suppose there's a
creative output make something out of a
min my friend bin right and got away you
know we're working hard on that and so
hopefully it'll come to fruition sir
listen screenwriting is talking
definitely you're not limited that you
imagination you can take you can go
anywhere with it yep actually this idea
that in society that we've stuck to a
certain format got a fire everybody in
the path of their go in and it all the
world's going to do things a certain way
and to the right reason you can do what
you want to do with script and you can
tell a story and you can speak to the
world change in some cases you can
change the world anything by the way the
things are put across but I think that's
what's taught me there's actually a
platform to really make a point
sometimes and the jungle he's trying to
search and Victor it Sam when do I right
when do I right I ride maze there any of
a structured I'm a time when I go right
okay this is when i'm going to write but
i heard a lot of people say they write
in the mornings but and and i can't i
will structure make notes in the order
but it's usually late at night I just
spring about a bed and I'll be like oh
right this idea haven't got to get it
down the Mount aren't we've done that
it's ridiculous yeah the screenwriting
my goals would be I really like the idea
I like being a consultant looking
through other people's scripts and
editing and you know reading those and
giving notes constructive feedback on
those that's something I really want to
do their kind of script really doing
that but so we screenwriting unit south
I'd love to have an opportunity to just
write something brilliant and draft get
free room and get it through to a point
where yes be
may that be like a proper feature length
or something like that but so I went in
short film to the minute i'm making
tryna ride for but that's me nice meow i
look forward to hearing everybody else's
videos and yeah